according to those rules Ryan is super
straight and Nick is super gay
[Music]
all right in this situation try to guess
what this guy did wrong okay easy so
there's this dude his name is Miguel
Alvaro he's from Portugal and he's
um on a vacation all by himself in
Istanbul that's where he messed up our
first mistake all right sorry why what's
wrong with that I thought people go
there to get a plastic surgery or
Istanbul we just want to be judgy okay
he went by himself Nadeem went by
himself I want to do a trip by myself
but you should go to somewhere you guys
aren't playing this game right okay are
you on our team or what the [__] is it
just mean Anthony
so he goes to meet a friend for lunch he
doesn't really know much about the city
so he sees a police officer and decides
to ask the officer for direction [__]
up again please aren't your friends yep
oh yeah those countries
gotta be careful they're they're corrupt
as soon as they um as soon as they as
soon as she talks to them they grab him
by the arm and then one of them hits
them in the ribs push him against the
van uh hit him on the shoulder [__] up
and they arrested him for traveling by
himself
I mean Anthony are right
we're playing this game right okay this
isn't turkey yeah what do you what what
did he do why did he deserve this we're
strict laws
or something or ask the directions
why do you go talk to the cop wait so he
was looking for places to go eat he was
just looking for directions you got to
do that before he goes to the
destination that's what he was like we
are not Yelp yeah yeah yeah you need to
have an itinerary before you go to the
location but they arrested him though
yeah because he was being annoying
probably he was asking too many
questions maybe he was like he's like
what's a Cool vibe here what's a cool
trendy
so far he did he didn't say he didn't
say anything I know why it's illegal to
be a food blogger in Turkey
we hate you [__] food bloggers he's
definitely not food vlogging so here so
here's what happened next so they take
him he spends like five hours in the
police van he's told to shut up and be
quiet
um he ends up uh for for 13 hours he's
in the police van it takes 17 hours to
drive to the eastern border which is
where they took him 13 hours yeah and
then he ends up he ends up in this uh
like a Detention Center where he
describes like that it's like full of
like maggots
it's like really gross conditions
what did this guy do to deserve this I
don't think he did anything wrong the
[__] yeah so he just asked for
directions he was released 20 days later
I think they were just [__] with him
maybe he had the wrong guy he had a they
didn't have the wrong guy what was he
Wang oh maybe they did I don't know uh
you wanna see what he looks like did he
have a t-shirt that said [__] did you
say [__] Turkish cops does that look
like a race thing
that's why look that [__] looks
photoshopped as hell yeah okay you guys
ready for the reason yeah
this is from the actual police Okay so
this guy what's his name again Miguel
Alvaro was arrested because he looked
gay
no I I heard that they're banning like
transgender like stuff like that and
yeah
[Laughter]
you gotta just be careful
bro what the [__] you people are nuts
dude
he actually is gay oh [__] damn their
gaydar was on oh [__] oh no
he didn't say he's not gay yeah but but
they didn't give him a chance
maybe it was a look maybe it's the way
he yeah maybe he was the way he talked
to them yeah because he's like do you
guys know any good places to eat and he
goes oh he's a gay get him they were
startled dude
Yeah so basically what happened
interesting that you said they got the
wrong guy so what happened there was
like a gay uh demonstration
that was happening in the city at the
same time that I think they had been
asked to disburse or it got unruly or
something oh so he thought he was a part
of those they thought he was part of
that but he didn't even know that that
was going on he's like I just flew in
wrong place wrong time he had no idea
that's why you got to do your research
before you get to the [__] spot
you're absolutely right it's not illegal
to be gay but they are cracking down
like they just don't like it yeah that
[__] sucks it's becoming an
increasingly hostile place for lgbtq
plus uh and uh there's been a ban on
Pride events since 2015. oh so you can't
do Pride events if I did some research
and I was going to a country where
they're like they beat the Chinese
people I'm not gonna go there bro that's
true though like I'm not gonna go like
as much as it sucks it's like that's
like you know you're going into another
place of rules you got to understand
what the rules are you know what I'm
saying why would you want to go to a
place you're not you're not really
welcomed at anyway that's what I'm
saying why would you want to spend your
money how much anxiety you would have
walking around trying to just be like oh
I want to eat and then you're worried
about you know your safety being Chinese
and getting beat up they probably got a
[__] ass like in Chinese yeah
yeah dude I don't know especially 99.9
yeah oh dude and if I showed them my 23
I will show it to them because I won't
shut the [__] up about it and they're
gonna beat me up dude can you imagine
Nick walking up to someone they're like
hey you know any good places to eat here
I don't like China man China man
they start beating his ass up that's
crazy that they that's wild
20 days 20 days dude and then they're
just like all right see you later yeah
they're like oh you weren't part of that
yeah just kidding yeah my bad Oh wrong
guy yeah don't like don't be gay next
time you're here oh you missed your
flight oh all right what was the point
of the 20 days is that like the actual
amount of days they think it's gonna
help cool off the gayness or something
here's so it says so stupid the actual
quote is that he was arrested they
arrested him because he looked gay
before allegedly detaining him for 20
days I think it's just the processing
and then to to prove that it wasn't a
different process
yeah I mean is he's gay so I mean it
would have been they don't have the
files
what are you they don't have the
Manpower it would have been funny if he
was straight but because he's gay that's
really [__] up yeah wait what do you
mean
what do you mean so hate crime dude if
he was straight that would have been
really funny because they assumed he was
gay and he was like I'm just I'm
straight what is a what is so gay about
me like I'm not gay and then like but if
he's but because it's gay it's a hate
crime it's crazy too that that they
didn't even like you said they didn't
confirm that he was gay they said he
looked gay I think people police
differently across the world that means
that you don't even have to be again
that means you just can't look the
official statement yeah yeah yeah he
looked again yeah he looked like he was
gay so I'm gonna arrest him for 20 days
make sure he doesn't get back home but
that's that's just like why does this
guy look good and clean and smell good
you know what I mean does he look that
gay to you guys but they were right look
he looks put together bro when you see
when you do this
he looks
he looks Annie so they're saying any
handsome good-looking clean well-dressed
guy they're like they're like he's
definitely good because they didn't say
that he sounded gay he looked again
that means they made the decision before
he spoke they just the partners they
just looked at each other and like yeah
that's like I'm married it's like him
wearing a pride flag like his whole
wardrobe was just that I mean maybe it
wasn't like super short shorts maybe he
had a little bit of that you know walk
it looked like you oh never mind that's
not the actual picture it might not be
no I got I gotta stand up and move my
hips a little bit but my friend was uh
doing like that the the Bible missionary
like stuff out in um Afghanistan
and um he doesn't have a mustache but
that's like a whole thing like you gotta
have a mustache to be a man and he said
they would roast them every day oh he
just couldn't grow them they would call
him gay no no like
like or some facial hair right so for
him he didn't know but they would just
be like what are you gay and they would
like every day get like Bully that's so
funny he's getting bullied by the people
he's trying to preach to
he couldn't connect to them unless he
grew the beer because they're like why
don't you have a mustache like oh he
must be gay we can't take his word for
it yeah they're just they think it's so
funny that he can't have a must of those
rules Ryan is super straight and [__]
yeah dude look at me bro I need like
eight months to grow up like a little
fuma and [__] yeah they're like what are
you a girl you don't have a mustache
dude that sucks it's like little boys
would be making fun of them like he
doesn't have a mustache damn that's
messed up yeah but yeah they said that
during that time
um
149 people were detained for gay
demonstrations
this kind of proves how harsh their laws
are though because like if this guy just
walks around he's just asking for the
word he's just being a normal you know
where a Quiznos is and he's like getting
[__] up and [__] you gotta like put on
a straight voice to ask about questions
I feel like those those countries over
there are a lot like strict I just in
Dubai and uh
you can't even say the f word yeah if uh
you said if you get caught saying the f
word one it's illegal you get can get up
to a year of jail time and then find 10
000 durhams and wow you can't even say
words like that lady who got arrested
for yelling at the rent a car at the at
the airport I didn't see that she like
left her wallet in the rental car and
they were she was like oh can I get my
wallet out and they were like oh you
have to pay for us to bring the car back
and then she started shouting at them
and she got arrested and the the charge
said for for raising her voice in public
because women aren't allowed to yell
what guys are yeah whoa she was supposed
to get a man to yell for her basically
this is in Dubai I should have hired
another guy off hire him that'll be dope
you can have a hired Yeller
you hear that does that make you want to
be like tomorrow
I'm booking my flight right now I'm
gonna buy property
they're they're gonna legal to be gay so
it's it's beyond the law it's the
sentiment it's the climate that's
probably worse than the law that's very
true you know they don't even have to
wait for things to be illegal illegal
they just don't like you yeah that's
really rough cops choice that day
exactly yeah just like cops yeah cops
all around the world a little funny huh
it's like morality police like what you
were saying for like Muslim residents in
Malaysia or something yeah they have
different rules for them
are you a blue supporter oh blues
Buddhist supporter
you look like you have a police academy
shirt on oh no there's a fire department
along those lines he was about to judge
us are you a blue supporter
[Music]